bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
manifestants qui jugent ces mesures
sanitaires le pass sanitaires notamment
libertines
écoutez le pass annie terre est un outil
dont l'objectif principal est de
contraindre légèrement la population à
se faire vacciner le plus rapidement
possible et en masse d'ailleurs ça
fonctionne depuis le discours du
président de la république
environ 10 millions de personnes qui
étaient peut-être hésitante qui
attendaient et bien ont reçu ce message
comme un signal de départ pour aller se
faire vacciner et aujourd'hui la france
et le 12e pays dans le monde en termes
de vaccination de sa population et ceci
va jouer de façon très importante à la
rentrée car comme vous le savez
évidemment la vaccination lui le risque
de contamination est réduit le risque de
faire une forme grave de la maladie
aujourd'hui c'est un prêt de laisser
plus de 60% de la population française
car sur un schéma vaccinal complet tant
qu'il n'y aura pas plus encore vaccinés
en france des mesures telles que le pass
and i ter resteront indispensables
alors le pas sanitaire est un outil qui
est circonscrit dans le temps
théoriquement il devrait s'interrompre
le 15 novembre
bien sûr il avait pour but
essentiellement de pousser les hésitants
un certain nombre de personnes très
réfractaires à la vaccination de se
feront probablement pas vaccinés à
sanitaires ou pas
maintenant
on va dire on verra qu'est ce qu'il en
sera en septembre octobre si il existe
un découplage
important entre les contaminations que
l'on sait
inéluctablement
en augmentation et les patients à
l'hôpital et bien si il y à un tel
découplage on sera content du taux de
vaccination actuelle est probablement le
pass annie terre disparaîtra si l
inverse malheureusement ce découplage
n'a pas lieu et que les hôpitaux sont
saturés et bien là probablement il
faudra même peut-être en arriver à un
certain nombre de mesures de restriction
voire en contraire imposer le pass annie
terre dans des activités encore plus
quotidienne et se joint à ce débat
gérard filoche porte parole de la gauche
démocratique et sociale merci d'être
avec nous est ce que vous vous diriez
que emmanuel macron est dans une logique
de confrontation confrontation entre une
majorité silencieuse et responsables de
primo vacciner pour reprendre les termes
de l'exécutif et une minorité
capricieux des réfractaires à
l'injection à l'injection selon
l'expression cette fois ci du porte
parole du gouvernement gabriella talus
minorité capricieuse que le chef de
l'état cherche à marginaliser
moi je crois qu'il ya une majorité de
gens qui ne comprennent pas les
retournements successifs des manuels
macron depuis 18 mois il a tellement
tenue de langage différent depuis la
sphère dégel du masque des soins
déconfinement et maintenant des vaccins
qui aiment très grande méfiance dans la
population et c'est ça qui fait que ça
ne passe pas parce que normalement s'il
y avait confiance en gouvernement on
pourrait atteindre comme je le souhaite
100% de vaccination mais comme il n'y a
pas de confiance dans le gouvernement
et comme la les retournements successifs
de matheron depuis 18 mois ont dérouté
déboussolé des millions de gens alors là
pourquoi on a des manifestations et
pourquoi on a tant de mal à obtenir 100%
de vaccination c'est la faute entière du
gouvernement
on peut pas avoir dit blanc un jour noir
un autre rouse un autre réseau d'un
dernier et les gens et il va lancer pas
confiance alors je me méfie du vaccin
ils n'ont pas raison parce que je pense
que avec le le vaccin il ya moins de
risque que 109 axa c'est aussi simple
que ça il ya sans doute des risques mais
on voit bien aujourd'hui les chiffres
sont confirmés que huit personnes sur
dix qui est sont hospitalisés le sont
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été vaccinés donc
il faut choisir
cette idée d'une renault mégane est ce
que il ya une forme de responsabilité de
la part de l'exécutif un souci dans la
communication politique qui pourrait
expliquer cette forme de défiance à
l'égard de la vaccination
oui il est probable que les choses n'ont
peut-être pas été présentée de la
meilleure façon en tout cas dans
l'esprit d'un certain nombre de
personnes on a associé la stratégie de
santé publique de vaccination de masse à
un régime politique quoi en parti
politique ou président de la république
en fait ces deux choses totalement
séparés bien sûr la stratégie et
annoncer mise en pratique par le
gouvernement maintenant cette stratégie
a des bases scientifiques
d'ailleurs tout gouvernement quelle
qu'en soit la couleur y compris de ceux
qui manifestent aurait adopté la même
attitude c'est à dire encourager la
vaccination de masse car évidemment s'il
ne l'avait pas fait il aurait été
coupable bien sûr
de prendre un risque majeur de saturer
les hôpitaux et donc d'entraîner des
décès un dut en pratique évidemment il
faut bien essayer de dissocier la
vaccination de toute idée politique
c'est deux choses totalement séparés
mais c'est vrai qu'il y as probable ans
de la marge améliorée
la présentation de de l'intérêt de la
vaccination au grand public gérard
filoche la gestion la crise est devenue
politique qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ceux qu'ils dénoncent une forme
d'opportunisme politique faisant
référence aux parties crie même la
fronde cet été mais bien sûr ces
politiques madame le cantinier à la
menace du pain moi je suis pour cent
pour cent de vaccination et je suis à
100% contre le pass sanitaires et je
crois des millions de gens partagent
cette opinion et pourquoi contre le pas
salutaire parce qu'on a mené les gens de
perdre leur travail on a menacé les gens
des licences on a menacé les gens d'être
mises à pied on a menacé les gens d'être
sanctionné au début il a même été
question de 45000 euros d'amendé pour
les restaurateurs qui ne ferait pas de
contrôle ensuite ça a été diminué
légèrement revu on a dit que les gens
aux contrats à durée déterminée ne
pourrait pas continuer leur contrat ça a
été revue et maintenant on dit que c'est
le patron qui doit vérifier mais
pourtant ça va contre toutes nos
traditions juridiques la médecine du
travail est indépendante le secret
médical existe s'il doit y avoir un
problème c'est le médecin qui déclare
l'aptitude ou l'inaptitude tout ça est
violée piétinaient le droit du
licenciement il faut s'y opposait aux
licenciements faux pas des facilités on
a 7 millions de chômeurs on a 10
millions au pot c'est ça que les gens ne
comprennent pas la gestion de maquereau
est à 100% politique vous pouvez pas
dissocier les manifestations aujourd'hui
de la politique regarder les banderoles
laissons tout contre macron moi je
voudrais qu'elle et banderoles contre le
licenciement moi je voudrais des quais
les banderoles pour le respect de la
médecine du travail moi je voudrais
qu'il ya des banderoles pour le secret
médical moi je voudrais qu'elle des
banderoles pour contre le les gros
trusts pharmaceutiques de façon à
imposer la transparence des contrats la
gratuité des brevets et la circulation
des vaccins je suis pour la vaccination
mais je pense que spontanément des
millions de gens sauraient pour aider
filerait pour il ya des milliards
d'humains qui volait de vacciner en ce
moment et pourquoi ça va mal ici et
d'ailleurs le réseau de pays quand ça va
mal aussi c'est parce que le pouvoir en
place a pas suivis faire faut susciter
de la confiance de l'adhésion moi je
pense que seule la gauche unie pour elle
faire mais mâcon n'a aucune chance de le
faire il a utilisé la schlague la menace
il a utilisé le chantage et c'est le
quotidien aujourd'hui ils sentent âge on
insulte les gens qui ne comprennent plus
on leur dit aval attention vous êtes
vous est ce si vous êtes cela et on les
traite comme de haut comme les gilets
jaunes ont été traités dans le passé
c'est pas normal de faire ça chaque fois
que macro veron ou attal agresse les
manifestants
il les renforce chaque fois qu'ils ne
donnent pas sentiment de conscience il
les renforce et moi ce que je voudrais
c'est que les manifestants il est des
bons mots d'ordre contre macron je les
respecte je partage pas beaucoup de leur
inquiétude parce que je répète que je
suis pour la vaccination et je suis
content le passant sanitaire et que je
dissocie les deux mois mais je les
respecte je trouve qu'ils devraient
seulement avoir des modèles constructif
c'est pas moi je vais pas leur imposer
les banderoles amap la gd cependant les
sujets sur lequel je voudrais qu'ils
manifestent mais je suis absolument
persuadé monsieur que tout cette
question est politique et que toute
cette question est la fota macron et à
ses errements et toute cette question
vient du fait qu'il ne sait pas parler
aux gens qui ne s'est pas leur donner
confiance ekin les gens n'ont plus
confiance en lui quelle réaction bruno
megaman de sept visibles opposition
entre mesures sanitaires et les mesures
politiques quelles répercussions sur la
gestion de la crise sur la situation
sanitaire en france
écoutez en france à l'évidence il y
avait une réticence très importante
contre la vaccination
nous sommes dans une course de vitesse
entre invariants delta qui explose un
peu partout qui fait état de morts ou
l'a vu en tunisie en inde puis récemment
dans les antilles lorsque la vaccination
est insuffisante il ya donc une histoire
de temps je respecte tout à fait les
positions bien sûr qu'ils y ont dû qui
vient d'être dit évidemment si on avait
le temps et qu'on pouvait le faire dans
l'explication dans la pédagogie
je serai tout à fait favorable je suis
pas du tout spécialement en faveur du
pass annie terre malgré tout il fallait
en l'espace de 1 mois vacciner le plus
grand nombre car il faut savoir que pour
obtenir la protection après la
vaccination
nous avons besoin de six semaines au
minimum et donc de fait il faut que le
plus grand nombre étaient vaccinés de
façon complète vers la mi-septembre car
le virus donc le variant delta va
circuler massivement notamment grâce à
la réouverture des écoles des
universités la reprise des activités
sociales économiques et le
refroidissement du climat donc de fait
j'ai du mal à concevoir comment faire ça
sans passer par le passe à lithaire
d'ailleurs beaucoup de pays qui étaient
un peu dans cette situation avec auray
dire spontanément une certaine marge de
la population réfractaires ont adopté ce
type de mesures ceux qui ne l'ont pas
adopté comme les états unis par exemple
pour beaucoup de leur état et bien se
retrouve aujourd'hui largué en termes de
vaccination
et bien je vous parie que
malheureusement à partir d'octobre une
catastrophe sanitaire 6 annoncera
notamment dans certains états du sud je
vous laisse répondre gérard filoche
assez rapidement si vous le voulez bien
selon le mot de la fin oui oui mais je
j'ai l'opinion contraire un jeune
exprimer je pense pas qu'on puisse
persuadé par la répression mais qu'on
peut persuader pardo bonne explication
sincère a le respect la confiance et je
vous parie mois que plus il y aura de
menaces de chantage de de menaces de
licenciement d' de viol du droit du
travail de menaces de mise à pied de
menaces de suppression de salaire
plusieurs axa est bien moins ça marchera
la vaccination est une question de
confiance
il ya onze vaccins obligatoires en
france ça a été établie la confiance
pourquoi ça ne sera pas pour celui là
c'est parce que la méthode qui a été
utilisée la poêle à bois faut utiliser
les méthodes ont été utilisées avant
expliqué
pédagogiquement prouver montré que et ne
pas insulter les gens plus vous les
menaces et plus voulait dresser contre
le bac ça plus vouloir expliquer plus
vous fait parvenir le vaccin jusqu'à
haut et amplifier une fracture sociale
vous le savez graphique et par
conséquent ses fractures dans notre
société elle se reflète c'est pas des
gens étaient comme ça qu'on des lubies
donc le vaccin c'est parce qu'il n'ya
pas eu suffisamment de d'efforts de
santé avant ya pas il ya des déserts
médicaux les gens il ya un million de
personnes de plus de 75 ans qui ne sont
pas vaccinés elle devrait l'être mais
faut que le vaccin est fière chez eux
faut pas leur dire attendez on vous
demande un peu un jour au téléphone on
vous dit vous ali sous les laves vous
allez là on leur dira on va venir vous
voir vous expliquer votre médecin
généraliste va le faire mais pour ça
faut avoir assez de médecins va brasser
d'hôpitaux faut avoir assez de soignants
c'est à dire tout le contraire de la
politique budgétaire de macron qui a
saboté notre hôpital public depuis des
années
il faut de la pédagogie blessant
beaucoup c'est pas dur à comprendre
merci on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
ensemble merci beaucoup gérard filoche
je rappelle que cette porte parole de la
gauche démocratique et sociale merci à
vous bruno megaman chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris merci et à bientôt